hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well during the
account of Socrates trial that we find
in the work of Plato Socrates student
called the apology Socrates makes a very
important distinction between his
current or younger accusers his newer
accusers and the older accusers who have
been around for more than a generation
and who he thinks that that he has to
address first there are certain problems
with doing this and I've put some of
these up here the reason why Socrates
thinks that he needs to address the
charges that the older accusers are
making first before going to address the
the charges that mellitus and Anytus and
these young men these these young guys
who are sort of prosecuting him on
behalf of the city they on behalf of the
citizens for the charges of impiety were
atheism and corrupting the young before
he addresses those he feels that he has
to address these charges that have been
made for more than a generation against
him and foremost among these charges are
that Socrates theorizes about the
heavens and about earthly matters prying
into them that he has this
unconventional way of looking at things
and that Socrates makes the weaker
argument appear the stronger that that's
a particularly day
having charge and the way that Socrates
portrays this these older accusers have
prejudiced all of the people who are on
the jury or at least some of them
significant majority of them in thinking
that Socrates is this kind of guy and
you might say well why should that
matter you know when somebody's being
tried they're only being tried for the
crime that they're being tried for well
that's not really the case even in our
jury system but in ancient Greece and in
the ancient world in general character
was thought to be important and this
this trial ends up turning on some of
these these matters of character so
Socrates is saying look these these
people have been tiring and feathering
me for over a generation getting you to
think bad things about me so I have to
address that first acta to neutralize
those prejudices neutralize those
presumptions neutralize those mistaken
assumptions on your part before I go on
to address latest and these other
charges he says that these these older
accusers are more or less nameless that
he can't bring up instances almost weeks
you know want to make exception for a
playwright he mentions Aristophanes it
was a comic playwright who actually
targeted Socrates in a play which we
still possess called the clouds where
he's got Socrates acting like this kind
of guy basically being a charlatan and
snake oil salesman and you know telling
people that he's going to teach them for
for a fee that was another charge that
was made that he teaches takes money for
teaching and Socrates says well I've
been engaging in this practice for a
long time and it's made me a lot of
enemies it's aroused entity or animosity
against me I'm part of these people and
so then they would say these things and
some people didn't actually know any
better they heard it from other people
and they just sort of passed it on and
once it gets out there in the culture
it's very difficult to to extirpate it
to just root it out so let's think about
who these all
accusers are socrata Socrates tells a
story and I'm not going to go into the
entire story has it some very
interesting religious implications about
a friend of his going to the Oracle at
Delphi and asking this question about
Socrates and whether anybody was wiser
than socrates I'm reserving discussion
of that for another core concept
specifically on this notion of whether
Socrates actually has any knowledge of
wisdom and all the notion of learning
ignorance the upshot of this is that
socrates feels that he needs to go
around to all the people in his current
Athenian culture and question them as he
puts a cross examine them and it goes
around to people who have a reputation
for possessing wisdom or knowledge for
not just knowing a little bit about
something but for being very intelligent
for being the kind of person who can
explain things who can make sense out of
things the kind of person who you would
actually want to have in charge of
important projects or you would want to
pay attention to when they're giving
advice so he talks in terms of three or
actually four groups for when he begins
to explain why each person has brought
these charges on behalf of whom but
let's go through the story first so it
begins by going to a politician and I
think it's very helpful if we we avoid
associating the words that we see here
with our current 21st century
conceptions of what these roles entail
because they're a bit broader for
ancient Greece so politicians would be
people who are trying to seek office or
people who are holding office but more
broadly what it's referring to our
people who are concerned with taking an
active role within the city within the
political community with it guiding it
so this would include everybody you know
at the level of the PTA and a local
sewer board all the way up to you know
those who are setting for
domestic policy at the highest levels
every everybody in between would be a
politician if they're an office holder
or somebody was trying to hold office
somebody's arguing for something in a
certain respect those who we nowadays
call lobbyists would probably fit into
this class of politicians as well they
have a finger in the pie so to speak of
the political process those who are
involved in think tanks you know
fellowship recipients these people who
are writing white papers engaging in
policy analysis they would all fit into
this class of politicians so Socrates
goes to a politician and why is he think
of the politicians would have a
reputation for being particularly wise
well they are charged with some of the
most important duties and offices that
apply not only to their own private life
or their own private economy meaning
their household but the end of the
entire state that of the entire society
they're making decisions about when to
go to war or when not to go to war what
to charge for things what policies to
have towards these foreigners or these
foreigners how power should be
apportioned within the state so
presumably they're actually speaking
from from not just some sort of set of
opinions or biases or bright ideas on
their part but from some sort of
knowledge some measure of wisdom and
wisdom for the Greeks meant not only you
know what we normally associate with
being wise but also being able to manage
your affair as well so that your life
turns up well so the politician is
concerned not just with his or her own
life but with that of the the citizenry
in general and of the entire community
so Socrates goes to the politician he
questions him the politician has lots of
great ideas it turns out that he can't
adequately explain these ideas - Femi
ideas make sense of them to somebody
else he actually does not possess
knowledge he
best possesses what Plato is going to
call in other places or the Orthodox ax
right opinion and the politician is not
happy about the this result Socrates is
not happy about the resultant so he goes
on to the next guy and he goes up to the
next guy and the next guy and as it
turns out none of the politicians that
he's actually encountering in Athens of
his time turn out to have knowledge they
they're able to get people to get behind
their programs and policies they're able
to sound convincing but they don't
actually do so on the basis of
possessing rational knowledge that can
provide a full comprehensive account of
itself so Socrates then moves on to the
poet's if it's not the politicians that
have all of this down pat maybe it's the
poets and again we want to avoid
confusing poets today people who are
writing poetry and mainly you know going
to readings sometimes their English
teachers or literature teachers
oftentimes they hang around coffee shops
you know sometimes they wear Berets to
let you know that they're a poet or they
you know they talk in somewhat strange
language some of them live a very
effective kind of lifestyle poetry in
the Greek sense in the classic Greek
sense means something much much broader
we can think of it as the realm of
cultural products as such because it
included not only lyric poetry which
nowadays we tend to put into music don't
we so songwriters would be poets but it
also included epic poetry and dramatic
poetry tragedy and comedy and satyr
plays and whatever else you wanted to
put into that anybody who was working
with language and producing something
that would be entertaining beautiful
striking as a result is producing poetry
in that
respect so filmmakers would be poets in
in the ancient Greek sense TV writers
would be poets I suppose you could say
that literature writers would also fit
in with what they're what Socrates is
calling poetry as well so you know
somebody like Fyodor Dostoevsky or
GK Chesterton I suppose in a lot of
respects would be a poet in in Socrates
sense here so he goes to these poets and
you can tell by it by the the dialogue
itself that he's actually going to
people that he knows that are in Athens
at the time Athens was particularly
fortunate in that it had quite a few
quite quite good poets writing lyric
poetry talking about epic poetry writing
some new epic poetry from time to time
but especially writing comedy and
tragedy so Socrates goes to these guys
and he asks them to explain their verses
he asks them to actually say what is
going on here in this passage what is
this referring to and in his own words
he says any one of the bystanders
because it could have explained it just
as well as these guys did about their
own compositions so I realized that
perhaps they're not actually working on
the basis of some sort of wisdom or
knowledge about the things that they're
talking about so they range over a lot
of topics but rather perhaps are
divinely inspired or something along
those lines but in any case they don't
possess wisdom or knowledge so then I
went to the craftsman the people who
work particular trades so that would be
people like doctors or shipwrights
or suppose mathematicians or pot you
know pot makers or cobblers pick pick
whoever you like you know in our time
this would include everybody
from plumbers to those in factories
working the tape and banned section you
know learning how to package things I
suppose logistics would actually fall
under there these days
there's a lot of things that would fit
within this spectrum of the crafts and
Socrates says yeah you know it makes
sense these these guys know something
don't they they know how to do something
that's why we pay them that's why they
have some sort of product they have a
skilled trade so with respect to that
skilled trade so actually says these
guys actually do know something they can
make something happen if somebody's a
basket weaver he can weave a basket you
can't but the problem is you know that
old expression that to the person with a
Hammer Every Problem looks like a nail
that's what happens with the craftsmen
they assume that on the basis of having
mastery of one small area of human
knowledge that they possess knowledge
about things in general that they can go
from that from say we you know weaving
or pottery or medicine to talk about
human affairs in general that which is
the products of the politicians and the
poet's or perhaps the gods you know
doing theology or talk about natural
phenomena and the problem is is that
having one particular skill does not
automatically transfer a large into
having skills in everything or
possessing wisdom or knowledge about
everything so what happens in each case
is Socrates goes to these people and he
tests them he puts them to trial himself
oddly enough there are the first
accusers in this trial that he is
currently undergoing and in each case
what happens is he ends up alienating
them he ends up turning them against him
because nobody likes to be shown up
nobody likes to feel as if they know
something and then have somebody come
along and show them that they don't
actually know something
particularly if that person says oh I
don't know anything myself I just know
that you don't know what you're talking
about
and so he a lien AIT's the politicians
he a lien AIT's the poet's the alienates
of craftsman Plato also has Socrates
mention the red errs those are the
people who are teaching other people how
to use language the people who are
making speeches the people who are using
language to persuade other people and
sometimes teaching other people how to
speak persuasively how to speak well so
each one of these classes ends up
getting turned against Socrates and that
makes them willing to say these sorts of
things about him that hey this guy you
know he acts like he doesn't know
anything but look what a fool he made
out of me he must actually know
something he's just kind of withholding
it and he's doing these secret
experiments or inquiries of his own and
by the way that guy can also make bad
arguments look good because look at how
he fooled me
look at how he tricked me look at how he
upset my pretensions to actually having
knowledge or wisdom people don't like
that
Socrates adds to this the fact that
other younger men started going around
and kind of imitating Socrates whereas
Socrates was doing this in a according
to him a genuine spirit of inquiry
actually a sort of a religious vocation
he wanted to know who actually possesses
knowledge because he wanted knowledge
some younger men thought that this is a
lot of fun and so they go around to
these same people and start asking the
same sorts of questions and behaving in
a much more cynical or critical or
skeptical manner aimed at just tearing
these authority figures down so that got
for Socrates a very bad reputation among
certain classes of people and these are
powerful classes of people to alienate
you notice he didn't say the ordinaryjoe
or merchants or somebody like that or
laborers he goes around to the people
who
really have a stake in in the workings
of their society in the development and
ongoing projects of their culture and he
shows them up as not possessing or at
least not being able to show for their
own part the wisdom or knowledge that
they claim to have that other people
have accorded them as having so this
creates this environment of prejudice
against Socrates that he feels that he
has to explain and as best as he can
within a very short speech to try to
combat now the one last thing that I
want to point out about this is it
really a successful strategy on his part
to point out the fact that that these
are the reasons for the prejudices
against him evidently not because the
vote goes against him there's there's a
lot of other factors involved but he's
not he doesn't sound very optimistic
about the capacity to root out this
prejudice so what is he actually doing
there why is he talking about this in
the first place he wants his audience or
at least Plato wants us to see this in
in the Athenian audience he wants them
to be conscious of the fact that they
have been listening for a long time two
stories told about Socrates that don't
really have any genuine basis and that
they themselves did not really make an
inquiry into so they've they've been in
a certain way bad listeners also in a
certain respect bad citizens because
they haven't actually undertaken to find
out who is in fact damaging the youth
and who isn't who's actually benefiting
them so what is what is going on here
Plato is showing us exactly why Socrates
is in the bind that he's in and he's
suggesting something to us with a
broader lesson if you're going around
too
these classes of important people who
play crucial social roles who at least
seem to have some degree of knowledge or
wisdom and you're showing them up that
is going to make you quite unpopular and
it's going to create a situation that
could be kind of dangerous for you if
that's what philosophy does then
philosophy by its very nature is a kind
of dangerous enterprise